the afternoon drive host for kan for 25
years dan barreiro dan good morning how
are you it's good I'm doing well it's
good to hear your voice it's been a long
time I kind of thought you guys had
forgotten all about me you know might
whenever there's bad stuff then we
always call you
so I'm known for that I am connected to
most of the bad things especially wolf
Timberwolves related okay but what's
more surprising Derrick Rose dropping 50
last night or the Buffalo Bills beating
Minnesota in Minnesota earlier oh I
think that's a great question I think
it's the bills I do I mean I I don't I
don't even think it's actually close
believe it or not because it's still
it's still inexplicable when you look at
what else he Allen has done what else
the Buffalo Bills have done and by the
way as you probably know they didn't
just come in here and one out on a
bomber ruski or something they destroyed
the Vikings here and it took several
weeks for this team I think to sort of
you know kind of recover from that
let me stay with the Timberwolves right
now but Jimmy Butler's sitting out um
the strategy here is it just the
coincidence though I mean he just sat
out because he needed to sit out a game
or but what is the overall strategy and
will it work for Jimmy Butler to get out
of town well it it all depends on who
you want to believe
I mean we're here's that here's the
dilemma we got we got an owner who wants
to trade him and feels like they have to
trade them you have a coach who I'm
still not convinced is actually try is
doing the due diligence to be creative
to come up with the best deal because
tibs I think that's his security blanket
with this owner from the beginning has
been getting Jimmy Butler and the sill
was not that you're just going to get
we're gonna trade him it's going to
trade you know some of our young assets
to get Butler we're gonna keep them
these guys go way back they love each
other they work together and this was
going to be long-term and so I think
deep down Tibbs realizes that once he
trades Butler his days may well be
numbered and so yeah that's how
dysfunctional this is man is that you've
got an owner I don't even have an owner
and a coach or on the same page for you
know for very specific reasons and and
Butler I will add quickly
I love the the deal I was all in on it
he's easily their best two-way player
but he's lost me on this thing he's
utterly and completely lost me with the
way he's now basically terrorizing the
organization I mean he's he's here one
day and plays great the other day of
course against LeBron and then he saw
nobody believes that nobody can actually
say that with a straight face and by the
way if it if it is soreness or he's not
in shape that gets back to well whose
fault was that he did you know he didn't
show up for training camp until the very
end so it leaves Wolves fans with this
sort of we're how do you invest in a
team even though you know butler's
Butler helps you win how do you
emotionally invest in that you know
staying the course with Butler when you
know he wants out he's playing this game
where he's decided it's part of his
strategy to make sure the wolves don't
forget I'm not going to change my mind
don't think that you're going to kind of
ease me into staying how do you you know
I mean how do you even celebrate a good
victory that's that's the it's classic
Timberwolves I mean this is 30 years of
varying forms of dysfunction and this is
just the latest version of it I mean I
it's almost unprecedented I think well
if he had one of those contracts that
towns has or Wiggins would this be an
issue well he behind the scenes people
say no but he'd all along my
understanding is to get him that deal
they offered him as much as they could
this year without literally stripping
apart the rest of the team and this is
again where Butler loses me because he
was good they were going to be willing
to give him that money next year it was
all part of the process and Jimmy you
know again if you go back to when the
Bulls traded them one of the whispers
some of the whispers out of Chicago was
you know be careful what you got here
he's a hell of a two-way player but he's
become a performance artist a little bit
in it you know he it was the old he came
up the whole old-fashioned way work at
his rear end off defensive presence and
then building upon that sort of the the
guy that everybody doubted but once she
broke through he became a little bit
maybe a lot Hollywood and became
production guy and that's I think
that's why it's hard for me to trust
that well he's just exasperated with
these young guys uh we know the grass is
going to be greener for him on the other
side and again if I could sit down with
Butler
I'd say Jimmy one question for you name
me a GM in the league who if they had a
choice of keeping you or towns is going
to keep you because no one in their
right mind even if they're concerned
with some of the issues on towns
defensively even-aged given help
nobody's gonna do that and that's where
to me he's just he's just playing around
here and making it up as he goes along
but if we look at expectations this year
with Minnesota Timberwolves expectations
and the Vikings expectations who is more
likely to achieve those expectations
this year well I guess it depends on how
you define the expectations I mean the
the wall the Vikings expectations if you
go back to the start of the season and
the offseason very simply were we got to
take the next step we got to take the
last step which is we gotta at least get
to the bowl and God forbid maybe even
try to win one after losing four here
going way back with the Wolves I think
it was always more even before the
Butler drama ensued let's get into
playoffs again and let's win a series
let's see if we can build on it see I
thought this was going to be the first
half of the season was going to be okay
we gotta prove to Jimmy Butler that this
team really has a chance to go someplace
and then he will be willing to sign long
term that was I think the feeling before
all this stuff surfaced unfortunately
it's it's taken a turn for the you know
for the worse and so with Bulls it's
never you know a championship and that's
the irony here the minute they trade
Butler they're gonna be worse again you
know Derrick Rose story was a remarkable
a basketball story last night it was
ridiculous but in all honesty you know
he ain't going to do that a lot at this
point and the team is pretty flawed
depending on what you get in return and
that nobody expects you're gonna get
more than what 50 cents on the dollar
for him maybe 75 cents if you're really
lucky you know I even said if I am
Houston I give up those four first-round
picks if I can I can get Butler and I
would think in that environment
in Houston then you know you might be
able to succeed and make something work
I think they're desperate down there but
if I'm Minnesota
I don't want four first-round draft
picks that you know maybe in the 20s and
I'm not gonna be a get done help me now
or next year or really the year after
that to build something special here so
I'm with you I wouldn't I wouldn't have
done that now you know there's some
questions some people are wondering
whether Philly's struggling might get
them perked up a little bit a bit about
a deal but again we're back to if the
owner is the one who has to feel the
deals really and really be serious about
getting it done you know is in terms of
like even countering and you got dibs at
his general manager kind of going Laden
not really all that invested in the idea
of moving him then how do you even know
you're going to give yourself the best
chance at a deal I mean you could make
the argument that if the team the more
the team struggles I think they're 500
early four and four I think that the
easier it might be for even Tibbs all
these guys to say well it's what are we
doing with now you know we have to do
something at this particular Junction
always good to check in with you Dan
I'll talk to you in a couple of years I
get very emotional you know let's do it
once every five years we'll work thank
you Dan we appreciate you to them it's
been the afternoon hosted KF a n for 25
years Dan Barrera friend of the show for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]